ah okay all right
for those in the live-streamed world
this is another episode in our software
design meetings series we are talking
about our symbolic nor on that framework
we are in the late stages of getting
ready for another release and we will be
working on all kinds of interesting
details I think today um let's see I
think tally had something he wanted to
show first you want to go ahead and do
that sure I'll share my screen okay so
Jeremy got back to me with icon since
the last meeting we had which was also
touch streamed I think so if anyone's in
the audience there who remembers us
designing his own icons he can all see
what they actually look like I want to
see what they look like oh so we've got
graph uninitialized in initialize chain
and initialized and initialized and then
function with none this non learn about
function and then learn will function
and initialized and initialized so my
only comment is are we sure we don't
want the word uninitialized I I think we
got to be consistent um I think we need
to get Jeremy just for a minute here
just to try and finalize this I I would
put the uninitialized thing as a stamp
on top of those other icons just to make
it consistent with what we're doing with
letting a layout oh I tried that it
looks a little it's terrible in my view
um so what about the other way around
what if we move an initialized in linear
layer down we could I like seeing it as
a as a sort of dramatic you can't miss
it kind of thing let's get I mean see
what he has to say let's let's look at
the other items that you have here and
hopefully Jeremy can join us on that a
sure this is something long overdue and
this is let's aging classification and
you you you know doing em lists or
something
currently you'll see the loss decreasing
and that little plot in
probably progress window but you won't
see accuracy like you won't see they're
a rage see the picture see the picture
what is it what is it so this is a
second plot yeah what's the what's the
blue watch imaginary is that's some kind
of that kind some kind of estimation
that's validation so because I specified
a validation set yeah is there any we
must have a legend
it's you got to be careful like this
there's not much room around for legends
and things and also these plots have to
be as fast as possible but I don't
disagree maybe underneath well I mean
the question is what makes it obvious
that blue means validation and I don't
even understand what I'm exactly seeing
that what is the the error rate on the
validation set or I don't understand
what works so first let me turn let me
do this again without a validation set
impressed begs because about 1m 14
seconds is really monkey there did you
see that I did not let me a good crashed
um oh yeah I was gonna show with not
validation one minute 53 seconds you
mean that thing yeah that thing is
really not standard and wrong what would
you prefer I don't know but we have a
standard for how to represent that and
it's not that okay do I think do Jeremy
just trying I am yeah okay actually can
we go back well tally go ahead show this
just for a second or whatever second so
Jeremy my only problem with these is I
mean these these icons can clearly get
smaller as well do we think that there
should be more detail in them or do we
think that they have to look like this I
just did it felt like there could be
more layers for example in that net
chain thing I don't know what do you
think it would go wider it's hard to
deal with with that size and they can't
be smaller um they could be smaller but
I don't know that you'd get you know
maybe one more layer
I could add maybe one more alright
that's alright okay fine then let's
leave it do we need arrows in the
network in the net graph are those
relevant tally could you want to comment
on that we could have errors yeah okay
Jeremy doesn't think it makes it too
cluttered I really small ones I think
would be okay and the net chain does
look like it could be slightly smaller
it looks
I agreed a little big and course yeah
alright okay there's two comments okay
the the real comment though is about the
uninitialized thing we have the same
consistency here between the stamp and
the linear layer and the you know yeah I
personally like the stamp because I like
seeing that you know it's really this is
really not a serious thing it's bit
uninitialized I'll give a sense of what
the uninitialized stamp looks like when
it's on the icons let's like take wears
a gray one
what I do is a green one
let's down the head down fun
and then there's an overlay just some
code I have to get art matting a box I
mean that looks gross to my view to my
mind I don't know I mean with the text
well I understand but but I mean the
arrows could get even lighter for
example in that case I personally rather
like that I rather like kind of stamping
it as uninitialized you know this isn't
going to work
Jeremy I wish we could outline the text
a little bit so it wouldn't have been
right on top of these hard lines fine
then then do that I mean put it put it
put it you know put a platform behind
the text do you mean like a little box
around the table just put you can go
ahead and do that right now telly I mean
you could just say background color
arrow whatever for the text definitely
better yeah it's definitely better
maybe opacity or can you do yeah is it a
white do gray level of like 1 comma 0.5
and do we have to do the same thing on
the W then I would think so okay I'll
try the notes oh you're on gray - so got
to be careful with your background color
yeah that's what it'll look like
well that but you haven't grade down the
the that's the wrong font as it happens
look this font is a much narrower font
okay listen it's going to
but by putting some kind of background
color on the on the uninitialized wood
it'll make it work do we know what color
that backgrounds gonna be though if it's
inheriting from panel that platform
dependent we don't know what the color
is soon yeah but it's roughly gray it's
it's gray it's just different shades on
different platforms windows it's white
isn't it like pretty much white I don't
think so
well I don't know but I think nobody on
this call probably is using a Windows
machine yeah I have an idea every
Windows machine put some new stuff and
I'll check but I think it's what okay
all right well anyway look I think we
can conclude this here can we I mean
what you've got is how should we
conclude this should should Jeremy send
you some specs should you send your code
to Jeremy and he could just tweak it
himself or what what's the right way to
do this I can I consent I can send him
to uninitialized I don't I mean I'm not
even wedded to that font or anything so
I can send him although it's nice that
this one is very small I can send him
this code here and then he can you can
even generate any SVG for or generate
new graphics objects for we can just
edit this code I think I mean janitor
yeah yeah that's fine
just give it to him in a nicely packaged
form for each for each of those icons
just give them a piece of code okay um
okay now you were showing one more
graphical thing yeah these icons look
nice these are these are definitely a
nice consistent improvement
that's a weird aspect ratio which that
panel panel yeah are they typically this
shape or in this case I'd go you know
plots to the right or something or to
column for the know the thing that's new
that's made its get this bad is that
we've gradually been accumulating useful
things to report here like batch size
method and now they're three more this
batch error around error alright so we
can we go to column the thing about that
is it's this error rate only sometimes
happens it doesn't happen for great
for your your labels your text at the
table you suggested an m1 then you would
put the two plots next to each other
rather than stacked or what um maybe
just a little bit bigger they wouldn't
it's already white in effect they
wouldn't have to get much bigger they
would benefit from being bigger I mean
these things you want to see detail for
these guys that's a good suggestion so I
mean we just break that into two columns
hopefully in some consistent place no
yeah maybe under time remaining fine I
mean should just be a multi-column I
mean that doesn't have to be yeah okay
how are we gonna resolve that time
elapsed thing um it's definitely not
right it it should be 1 : 26 or
something I don't know we've used that
in other places I just don't know um
somebody in the unit's group would know
that I mean worst case take a screenshot
and ask Michael trot he probably would
know okay when she just asked and he can
send it to whoever I mean probably Erik
weisstein probably has me take this
whole and this code has to be extremely
optimized so it's not gonna use not
gonna call out - no no I understand that
I understand that it's just a formatting
question if you want to use one coulomb
whatever or do we want to use you know
um no my trust yeah I'll just leave that
open and then I'll send it later
fine okay all right okay you were going
to show that thing about the validation
sets and scale so I can put a little
legend it'll probably be like a maybe a
dot that what is that random dot just
hanging it's the very first one so we
can't join it with anything because it's
the first one okay but what is this this
is the accuracy I mean the the error
rate and the loss but not on the
training set on the validation set
why so so it's less good on the
valuation set because never seen those
things before right it's it's begun to
overfit but so that's pretty interesting
but why are there more data points in
the training why they're more horizontal
data points in the training thing than
there are in the validation thing we get
a measurement every batch and there's
several batches per round but we only do
a validation run once per round okay
then it's often quite we're not
indicating the rounds I mean it would be
more consistent to indicate the rounds
by a dot in the in the orange curve as
well okay like one well yeah I mean is
that is it showing the dots and the blue
curve are at the at the times of rounds
it's that correct yeah so the point is
that the orange curve will bounce up and
down in between those round endings but
I think to be consistent you should show
the round endings although you might not
want to have a great big thing with tons
of dots in it I mean maybe the dots I'll
let less dramatic color I'm not sure
because there is no single round
measurement of the loss there's there's
only a whole bunch that you could
average together all right but the
question is is there any way of
capturing the fact that that's a
validation set that the blue is a
validation thing yeah I can do a little
how do you want me to do it like a
double dot of the line in it but it has
to be smallish well I mean we have a
standard way of doing legends none of
that stuff works in here it's got to be
10 times faster than ordinary plotting
code for it not to bring the slowdown
training I can't call out to ordinary
plotting could okay what about fine but
but then let's take a look at okay what
are we trying to communicate we're
trying to say go back and generate that
again yeah we're fundamentally trying to
say training set versus validation set
is that correct
yeah why is the error rate in green what
why is that why both of them blue for
the validation why is one orange one
green for the other thing they could
both be orange but I thought it'd be
nice if error is looks different from
loss but if they're both listen if
they're both mean to me it's like but
the validation error why is that why the
blue is the same and the or none I
understand the inconsistency okay why
don't we just make them both make green
orange
it looks nice to have them in different
colors but but it seems to me that if we
can have a pair of colors mm-hm
you know and another pair Jeremy do you
have a suggestion I agree well I mean
some cue shift from those two colors so
maybe I don't know maybe we got to go
more reddish for the top and we could go
blueish but maybe a different shade of
blue for the bottom so they'd pair like
a warms and cools okay well see your pet
you mean pair pair the things which are
the validation ones no I mean so I'd
connect the two lines in the plot so so
kind of a blue with a green plot I don't
think it matters that the validations
are the same color blues with the what
well I think it for the lost plot we
could go maybe reddish for the the
validation and for the error rate we
could go more blueish the one benefits
of pairing of having the identical
colors for the wedded age is that that
means we only need one legend we can put
between them hmm yeah you could yeah you
could definitely pair them up and
honestly the rounds could just be there
once right are they are they're in sync
between the two even sync yeah yeah so
you could have one round and at the
bottom a single legend with so we're
back to one color for error rate yeah
well what do you want to do like I don't
know I mean I've sent you an email so
you could do you could do both ways like
if they should if we share the
validation or if we have two different
validations
I don't maybe
if Charlie has a moment maybe he could
just try and you know keep yeah yeah
okay do that right now okay all right
what is this last thing the performance
goal thing is that something else um
yeah yeah this is just you know I think
it's pretty uncontroversial so there's
there's there's optimizations you can
use that privilege speed over memory and
the system's very controversial yes what
yeah it's particularly portent for GPUs
with memory there yeah Sid obviously
seem sensible I didn't know we'd Reno on
let's go for that train yeah I mean one
question is for like classify there's
different forms of memory there's like
we should look what they are we just put
those endless training there's all kinds
of things though let's see what is it
training speed actually I think there's
if you if you look at the latest version
there's even more stuff okay because we
have training speed and member and
training memory rather than speed and
memory okay kind of things yeah
everything you're doing training so
that's what so what so why isn't it just
memory and speed in the case of of okay
that's in courtesy why don't you accept
training speed and training memory as
well but we won't document that all
right cool okay anything else that we
need to see your screen for
somebody on our live stream is pointing
out that we should consider colors that
are friendly to colorblind folk thing to
see colors on I think there are other
cases where it really matters what the
colors are here the colors are really
mostly decorative we do try to be
careful about that when it actually when
the colors really really mean something
and also the validation is pretty much
guaranteed to be the validation Rasul or
error rate it's guaranteed to be bigger
than the training ulcerated so Isis
languish you can show which is which
yeah okay what are we what are we mainly
digging into and and Jeremy let us know
if you have something to show or um okay
what are we digging into here okay the
next thing is with the Ness encoders and
decoders okay so maybe I can share my
screen okay go ahead okay juice my
screen yep okay so these are
unfortunately they're not free fleshed
out yet but we are going to so just for
the context obviously the people know I
mean Ness encoders currently there's one
page for them and we want to stuff north
so this issue that we've had with
classifiers exactly it's a similar yeah
right yeah
so basically we want us to get a design
for these pages before asking the
documentation team to implement them
could we could we get brown bamboo here
because let's go directly okay so I
guess whilst we're waiting for Brian
there's one issue we want to discuss
right in the beginning which is the
question so at the moment the syntax is
that you have to have a list form so
like this NAT encoder then image etc so
the one thing we were thinking of was
that for documentation purposes it's
much cleaner if we love that that dev
list well sure
especially can you show one of the
complicated encoders that you but we we
put that on a list for a reason which is
we expected to have
options as the second argument didn't we
a really heavy breathing some kind it's
me fix themselves
um said could you show like a
complicated example one of this big one
of the news news yeah okay yeah so this
is about eight new encoders coming in
eleven point three and lots of them are
audio based so this is one example I'm
just going to make this bit bigger might
be but small one second
right back
so tally while Steven has gone was one
question I had was about if we want some
arguments to reserve an argument for the
type that gets returned for this thing
if there's a net array one day we'll
numeric array or whatever else you would
basically need a positional argument to
control what you want returned I mean
that applies to all encoders oh I see
what you saying so that's why we'd want
to maintain the list syntax
maybe I think that that when that day
arrives they should all emit um lorries
and then it's up to people to use normal
to - Drock the to unpack them to lists
and that's array I guess it doesn't
really matter it's not going to be that
different
putting the new dynamic object I don't
think net array is a carrier of data
I think net array is a it's like it's
what's used a net function it's the
symbolic tracer that builds the tape
when you do auto grad what it is and you
know and it's used it's also used as
like as a wrapper for indiarose when
you're doing a custom callback based
layer but it's not static data really
you know so I'm not sure about that
because for general training syntax that
we were thinking of supporting for
reinforcement learning and whatnot
you basically needs to change the arrays
resolve need to change or so it's it's
nice to have an actual array type that
can live on GPU etc yeah yeah I agree
it's mutable and such a mutable thing
but net encoders would never produce
those why would they produce those
because it can be a lot more efficient
hi guys I'm back sorry about that
no okay so did we get here
quite a bit to talk about before he
arrives so okay okay
go ahead okay so yeah so what we want to
discuss today is what is the design of
these pages one is discussing the audio
encoders they've got some common options
and yeah we haven't passed we haven't
accepted these names yet
we're not sure what to do with them for
various options and then the last thing
is going so the whole business about
some of them being symbols and some of
them being strings is pretty weird no
Bryan has to finish this current meeting
it's going to be about at least 15
minutes guys okay yeah we can keep them
as all strings well I just want to
understand again with this company's
office it is a symbol because that's a
rapper isn't it yeah it's some
complicated rapper for something
completely different it's completely
inappropriate for this yeah fine
um what's it an offset oh okay hold on a
second um okay
okay so what's the issue the issue is
how to give those parameters and this is
what there's several issues so one is um
we're putting forward formally the idea
of dropping that list in nation culture
I understand I understand but what we
what I was saying
before I had to go was that we had
previously wanted to package those
things in a list so that for two reasons
one well I think we imagined that we
would need options but what you're
saying is I mean the question is what
information do you have to provide to
specify a net encoder and you would say
well why don't you just provide the
whole net encoder object right whereas I
think before we were trying to make it
so that you could just provide that list
and that list will be enough to specify
the whole net encoder yah yah yah and we
just it turns out when we wrote the
documentation it's way clearer to
actually use the explicit rapper net
Khoda because it means that something
people can chase in the documentation
whereas if you just have this list
that's floating around you know it's
like net chained blah blah blah input
goes to a magical list with some strings
in it well I mean you're addressing the
question of how you package up the
documentation and that this page is you
know this is a different design because
we haven't had to do if you look at a
format page for example
it's just keyed by the name of the
format yeah exactly
oh I don't mean that format if you look
yeah it's got a gift gift I guess right
so there I mean this page is of a
different structure
did you change topic so you're not
talking about these new pages you know
let's go back but your argument for why
you want to do this it's partly because
of the pages not really no the argument
for why we want to drop the list is that
it's never been useful like there's no
place that it makes anything clearer
just makes can we try to remember why we
put it in the first place
I'm actually could you show me back on a
page which just the the main net encoder
page let's take a look at the diversity
of net encoders okay so these ones don't
exclude the new ones the new eight ones
that we've got so scaler image yeah look
the point about it is those things in a
sense qualify let's take tokens for
example that list in effect qualifies
the tokens thing it's it's almost um I
mean in other places sometimes we use a
rule you know tokens arrow whatever I
don't particularly like that in this
case but the whole point is that that is
the list of tokens is qualifying the
tokens I mean sure I would see it
differently because tokens has got a
whole bunch of knobs and whistles on it
and we don't show them in this list
because otherwise this table would be
way too cluttered
it's got like three different three
different arguments and like two to two
different options and think
yeah because you can say ignore case you
can give a splitting credit you can give
us like information about how it should
tokenize the input I mean it is a diesel
what is the bigger picture of of net
encoders I mean they're functions right
yeah that's what they are differentially
would take arbitrary data and produce
tenses of numeric tenses or something
right but there are functions that have
you know okay could we go back can we
look at the new net encoder page with
its various new that the draft of the
net encoder page so no I mean not that
one I mean the main net encoder page
it's gotta go to the main go to the the
draft of the main net encoder page the
CVS doc version lets you get stuck okay
I see sorry open nice one could just let
out you yeah that's right what is that
TOC open thing coming from is that a
utility of yours oh yeah yeah tally
grotus thing that's very small Oh could
you when Bryan joins us could you um
feed it to him and he can give it to
everybody else
seems like it's obviously useful thing
it doesn't even need the string honestly
it just you can work no symbol as well
okay okay okay that's all all kinds of
modern conveniences fine um okay so
let's look at this so what you're
telling me is that that tokens thing so
it so you scroll down on this page does
it describe the options for the tokens
case here it does yeah and there's a
little grammar for how you stand how you
specify the oh wait that's characters
that's not spoken but like yeah I mean
it's obvious that each of these needs
its own page yep I agree okay um
and that is essentially the non list
version is it's not a gimmick as such
but it's like there are two different
kinds of things here there is the
immediate qualification you know tokens
without the spec is meaningless isn't it
no it's nice because you can you just
get the word lists like English word
list is the default the default token
list cookies go up shop on that page to
scroll up to see the word tokens okay
hold on tokens oh I see in common
English words in in strings in a strain
as integers probably should say and
maybe in a string yeah okay
I see hmm what's bothering me is this
mixture between the options
specification of stuff and these raw you
know the raw positional thing are making
sense yeah I mean it's it's actually
kind of somewhat arbitrary but in the
same way that it's arbitrary for for
certain layers funkin convolution I
think you can give up to three arguments
and then after there they're just
options and that's a somewhat arbitrary
line that we decided well okay so what
approach to that is to give that an
option name but as a courtesy allow it
to be given as an argument as well right
yes
I mean alternatively and what would make
me probably happier is to continue to
support that list form okay but not but
put but take the options out of the list
form and have the possibility of having
that thing which is given in the list
form be also specified using options or
an association okay that makes sense so
in the case of image with a size there
you know you can either just use image
you just stop challenge sorry
you want to show again I was raised it's
not ring because that doesn't make me
any happier because it's it's it would
technically be more verbose than it is
now not less for both because you'd have
to introduce that Association as a
second argument and that means an extra
four characters well I doesn't need to
be an association you can just have them
you know at the top level I don't have a
problem with that I don't think okay why
not going not a big fan of things that
look like options but are actually
strings and I mean things like image
size sigh sigh sigh look the problem is
you want to use things like image size
to represent the width height thing
where I suspect yeah you know we could
turn these Inter's into system symbols
here's what we kind of do we can't
afford to document them with the same
level of rigor at least for this version
as we document all the others all the
ordinary that will be crazy you do not
want a image net encoder an audio M FCC
net encoder that will be crazy what do
you mean no no I don't mean like that no
no no you completely miss miss dizzy
I'm saying I'm I'm happy with idea that
we turn all these strings into pure
symbols
no way no way there's a there's all
kinds of weird nonsense that will be
specific to some particular you know
favorite net encoder for you know smells
or something yeah that's right oh yeah I
agree with that
alright so they have to remain strings
then well it could be those that there's
positional arguments and we have string
firts no no no look no no look the issue
is that a small number of these things
happen to be symbols like window saw
well window size is not right either
that's not right that has to do with the
size or window on your screen here phone
that's playing fast and loose some for
sample rate is there that for sure
yes that is their um look I think the
right thing is to make them all strings
and a few of them accept them as symbols
and it is possible you know cuz there's
nothing special about sample rate here
relative to all the other types of
features of this net encoder yeah there
can be a string I mean it's actually the
way it's implemented now if a symbol
happens to be named the right thing it
will work it's not it's not documented
like that but so you could use sample
rate just because it happens to have the
right symbol right look let's make them
all strings I think it's a good
principle okay fine
and and okay so then let's talk about
what the net encoder
okay so fundamentally a make a string
name also for the thing that could be
given as as a list form okay okay so you
mean okay so like oh sorry image yeah so
in that case I would have a quotes image
size okay fine so does the string image
size and then some default yeah
automatically automatic then in the
usages we drop we drop the second and
third usage and we just say as tensors
and we and we leave it up to the notes
to say what the default image size is
I'm sorry what do you think I see so
this thing has no no no no don't delete
that undo undo I'm just not working and
when you're using talkie tools like this
so what I'm what I'm suggesting is if if
we move away from these positional
arguments which i think is fine
we Steven what if we just formalized
this right you can provide any of these
is positional just as long as it's in
the order of that table there no way no
way insane all in one state so what I'm
I'm suggesting very simple okay
that second usage is a list usage list
you know image comma size in a list
okay net encoder of open list Sebastian
okay I see you know I could have open
lists and then sighs it's the wrong font
but yeah yeah whatever we exactly the
same as it was before right and
identical to what it was before and that
is to be equivalent to a net encoder of
quotes image comic quotes image size
arrow what I see as our arrow the size
thing so what is this list give us the
cleanliness
it is a qualification it's just pure
design cleanliness seriously what yeah
okay I'll tell you what it gives us okay
it could be that that second element
there needs to be something that has the
structural form of one of those things
that's a string arrow blah you get what
I'm saying
I see so like a rule yeah it could
happen to need to be a rule in which
case you've got an ambiguous syntax
otherwise it's just cleanliness and then
the alternative is the way we document
this that those particular things are
just short hands for people who want to
use you know where it's just easier
where you only need to give one
parameter that okay but you could and
this is very similar to the way that we
do it for form object and interpreter
and so on um you could give the full the
full version with with them you know
rules for everything that makes sense I
wish we could kill that there thing is
why do you want to kill it it's fine
what's what's wrong with it well when
you have to type it out as many times as
we do it's like it's actually really
annoying type out what tally you're not
seriously trying to save yourself two
characters or
you yes is that what you're doing then
do that fun no no what I find
frustrating about this is like we so
close to having something that acts like
other functions because other functions
don't insist that positional arguments
are wrapped in a special list right to
distinguish them Tally's they're not
positional arguments they're not this is
because this thing is a multi-function
so to speak right that isn't it is a
function who is who's complete operation
is being sort of Bank switched by its
first string argument yeah right it's
really not the same as an ordinary
function because you can't document oh
the second argument is its size by the
way a comment from our live stream from
swish ka why is it even called net
encoder it's not only useful for neuron
that's right
which is an interesting I mean is it is
it only useful for neural nuts or is it
useful for other things so you solve
other things it's whatever you want to
ya get a numeric representation of some
non numeric objects although where else
I mean for example would it be useful in
something like I don't know dimension
reduction or something it's probably
implicitly used there three years in all
those places and classify dimension
reduce anywhere in machine learning
where you need a sort of representation
that's always used as attend use our
knit encoder no okay so the main thing
is that we have very efficient out of
core loaders so if you want to import
data into Mathematica from images or
something it's vastly faster to do it
with this well this comment that is not
just useful for machine you know for
neural nets is in fact true yeah so
where else would it be used in general
so anyway in machine learning that
requires image data or audio data
it'll be used although the fact is what
it's doing is it's turning everything
into numeric tensors exactly that's all
that machine learning can ever use at
the moment and it doesn't operate on
like us it doesn't there's a one-to-one
correspondence between its inputs and
its outputs so it can't operate on a
file and produce five different
whatever's tensors has to produce one
tensor for each input it has that means
it's not really a general-purpose import
T thing well wait a second so I see so
the possibility the thing you were
implicitly suggesting is there are two
analogies here one is interpreter and
the other is import yeah right because
you know you import an image and in our
language it turns into an image but in
principle it could just turn into a
array of numbers exactly this is kind of
a numeric interpreter I think that's the
fair way of talking about it yeah that's
a good way of talking what
hmm interesting so I mean it's still a
bit messy right now because it's
basically you know you're taking this
thing it's got some column space it's
got you know it's a little bit by the
way don't forget that you've your second
line there is wrong your ever something
that no no no no no in the in the box at
the top that's not the size is wrong
because you've got yeah the description
is wrong with three times yeah fine okay
sorry I mean these these pages will
completely rewrite just okay okay I'd
like actually you've proposed something
which is it's stricter than what you're
suggesting Stephen leicht I'm very happy
that you agree that the options could
could be effectively options to net
encoder but I think combining that with
this listing of really against that what
if we allow it but we don't document it
and instead we change one of our
documentation examples to use the
explicit thing which is like net encode
an image comma image size goes to 250
128 if you want to I mean if you want to
i'm only you know you're being a bit
hypocritical here because you were the
one who was just complaining that it was
too long too tight boys an excuse I
never really believed in its that net
encode is already encapsulating and then
this list thing is another form of
basically pointless encapsulation
syntactic encapsulation that's what I'm
really against is the kind of is the the
depth of a paucity of it well I okay
look the question is really is it really
common to want to specify that image
size argument yes
it's very common okay I think you should
provide this simplified form of it just
like an interpreter there's a simplified
form in the case where you just want to
give a default value and you know we've
got to give a type in a default value
and if you want to give the whole you
know elaborate thing with hinting and so
on and restrictions then you have to
give something more complicated what
about an arrow instead of in lists like
that image goes well work because
because it's gonna look like the other
arguments I think it's okay really
really don't like it
okay can we okay I
yeah tally if I might point it out you
were the one I mean you know this is
exactly what we had designed before now
you forced us to add this this extra
level of miss list yes I did and I'm
glad I did because now now look we don't
have the problem of having you know this
positional thing that could have some
weird misinterpretation that's the hard
kind of thing that you've adduced to
support this yes the rest of it is pure
aesthetics that has never happened
what's in those encoders and decoders
there's no case where there's a an
argument to thin code or decoder that
can be confused with non power right
okay it hasn't happened so far but tally
if you want it if you really want to not
document these list forms I guess it's
okay I think they should be documented
if they are a very common form but it's
I don't think it's critical I please
just consider it further okay
I I think it's a good idea to have these
less forms okay we've got bright do we
have Brian here I'm here hi
okay we are looking at these subsidiary
pages for net encoders which we want to
break out much like the classifier pages
yeah now I'm not quite sure given that
we're removing these list forms I'm not
quite sure why we can't just have um
something like four classifiers where we
just say you know quote quotes image and
we put it just like we do for other
kinds of sub pages like this wait so
just so certain encoders there require
arguments certain arguments that they're
not optional well which ones
so if example like M such it requires
you to provide a class list okay please
you know that this thing that tally is
making such a fuss about with it with
the the just just put it in in a list
you know put that thing in it in a sub
list if it requires that then okay I I
think the way to document this is the
following I think I think probably the
the heading of the page should be CTC
beams such and this should be a net
decoder page and then it should say then
in the usage it should give you no net
decoder of CTC beam search etcetera etc
I agree I mean it's not really any
different than what we do for say
interpreters where it's just like that
and it requires interpreter wrapped
around it fine okay fine
does interpreter have cases where the
naked string doesn't do anything and you
have to wrap the naked string in
something the pages for these so you say
a semantic number interpreter type okay
but I guess the we still want to usage
if we have well yes in this case we want
a usage that means it's a different
design page but this is roughly you know
I would think this is roughly what its
gonna look like it's gonna say CTC beam
search paren net encoder at the top yeah
but it looks like a function page
because it actually is a function that
it evaluates if you want I mean you
might want that one of those summary
lines at the top what do you mean in
some real and that one that you were
just looking at for the case of whatever
that was was the thing you were just
looking at semantics number right so
there's a summary line that number in a
standard format on a natural language I
don't know whether the summary line it's
useful hmm yeah that might be good
because I think it's yeah hmm yeah
that's useful but if you have a you
still want to show like necessary
arguments for example yes fine but it's
going to need a slightly different
format again because we don't want it to
look I mean could you go back to the
your net encoder page mm-hm
it's just gonna need a slightly
different design I think but but it's
for example that the details section
probably should be open by default here
unlike on a function page just like it
was on that semantic into you know I see
like number or whatever it was page okay
fine yeah that makes sense
um so Brian how do these pages get how
do these
templates get get designed well the
templates the design of the templates
isn't necessarily doesn't necessarily
have to correspond with the final design
for the final design we would need to
get graphic design involved the template
could really just be if I have some idea
of what content you're expecting to be
on one of these pages I can whip up a
template pretty quickly so what it is
yeah it sounds like that there are some
of these written right the one we were
just looking at is in pretty decent
finished form I assume yeah and the only
difference is that you know it's this
semantic it's this line at the top
can we look back so in this case it
would say net decoder do we say net
Dakota type no net space decoder
I think it's Dakota type yeah possibly
and then we would say ah
so if there's a certain amount of
boilerplate about data comma prop blah
blah blah okay so what we've got is it
the case that for every net decoder net
encoder that you have options and you
have properties and only some of them
have properties and most have some of
them don't have options okay fine but
then but having those things be
separated sections seems like it will be
useful in this in this documentation yes
because they all have the same basic
structure definitely okay so that's so
Brian that's that's those become two
sections for your hey why don't you put
a little section right in there right
now so that you can say mr. Brown
appreciate it thank you
what is it again no no I mean where the
section is but I don't know where the
section thing is how do you do like come
on five just and so let me just just put
yeah any any big cell that will show up
ah okay anyway so it's okay you know
what you could just even if it's just
like a text cell that says properties
section here yeah I don't care
yeah fine exactly okay okay is there
only ever one head for these things so
you would you get an encoder and a
decoder for the same string that can be
yes yeah these are two different page
types encoders and decoders would be two
different page types often there will be
you know they'll they'll be appear so
there'll be an image encoder and an
image decoder but doesn't separate they
may have different do you want to link
them somehow in that case you know in a
prominent way yes I think you should say
okay so listen under C also you should
say you should have a thing that says
related encoders related and another one
related decoders probably and then it's
also it was slow yeah just copy the
holders page like a little pate I'm
thinking like like import/export format
you know that yes absolutely we need
that page will need a guide page which
will link off the of a neural net or in
general machine learning page and this
is related as well relate to decoders
related encode is related decoders and a
seal so and the seals know will be two
functions are these encoders and
decoders are these related enough that
it would could these be combined into a
single page that's not related I mean
they're like I wanted to suggest for one
second the question of in the future and
I you know these are still experimental
functions anyway but you know the
possibility that these becomes some kind
of an American Tourister thing that's
you know is that here's why it's not
quite an interpreters cuz that might be
what an input is but what is it is a
decoder well a decoder is a deserialize
er I mean this is
like serialization deserialization yeah
numeric serialized numeric deserialize
er except it's not quite serializing
minutes it's some June you might wonder
whether these things are realistically
useful elsewhere do you think that they
are because they're turning I mean
realistically in many cases or maybe I'm
wrong you know you've got a picture of a
dog and they're turning it into a random
sequence of numbers or am I perhaps
being unfair that there's more there's
more to the well I guess yeah there's a
few things that it does so one is it's
short it convert certain numbers but it
also has guarantees of certain type
guarantees like the sizes that you'll
get out the conforming spaces that
you'll get out like it conforms it to a
particular thing like the sure kind of
space would be the size will be the same
or that sort of thing I mean it is an
interesting thing to think about
generalizing and I wonder whether they I
mean the test of that is whether one can
actually whether one finds oneself
actually wanting to use it okay so first
question is is this a TN care about it
for other machine learning purposes and
then what other people might care about
it for example the hashing functions
this is is it is it a relevant way of
doing hashing not really because you you
probably want to hash something that you
know you want to get the actual data
that backs the thing the file and hash
does well exactly might if you want to
make a semantic hash this is more
relevant it's true but I mean there's
semantics hash methods for that and then
it doesn't need this necessarily right
would still yea it would still do this
actually you right like it for a somatic
hash for integers would probably use
this will conform it to a certain thing
and then woods hashes right right okay
um alright let's see what else I need to
go to something else in a minute what
else is there here that we need to cover
you can take a quick look at this plot
right the legend do you want to share
your screen oh I just sent our chat link
if you wanna okay
now that looks really nice don't you
think yeah yep um there's some
duplication I wasn't sure how to handle
that though I mean you have loss and
error rate on the side but but I don't
see you kind of have to repeat it in
legend we could remove it from the side
but I thought it's actually useful I
know but I mean if look the problem is
no if this isn't quite right because
you know really what it is is orange and
green are both training and blue is
validation yeah so that's what diligence
is no it isn't what the legend says the
legend says loss and error right so as
you know training loss training error
rate no but but but validation it's the
wrong that they're different you know
it's it's a different concept here um
may be mindful well what we could do
then if we had four colors as we could
stack the pairs of colors yeah and then
say training and validation so that you
know it's the orange green whatever
country's flag that is try to
immediately know um and you know
whatever it is to get what I'm saying
geremy so they're grouped by law how
would they be later on uh the point is
Jeremy that the orange and green lines
are both okay the museum waters in
camera loss what's that use your camera
to do this it's like at a little table
we have to make no no it's really simple
okay
the top panel shows loss for a the
training set and B the validation set
Jeremy yep okay the bottom panel shows a
the you know the loss or the error rate
for the training set and the validation
set okay okay um so to
right so what I'm suggesting is no I'm
not suggesting two legends I'm
suggesting if the colors okay one way to
do this that is clearly straightforward
it's just to make an orange curve just
make the green curve orange yeah into
training that invalidation said then
yeah yes yeah they're not
straightforward that makes more sense I
think here are we happy with orange and
blue because I just made up that orange
and that blue well as you noticed Jeremy
changed your blue yeah it was a little
too bright but but the other two colors
were pretty nice right our one of our
viewers suggests dashed line for
validation I wondered about that but I
don't think there's any particular
meaning to that there are the troubles
that with very long sessions it gets too
dense and the dashing looks quite odd
fair enough okay but but so the only I
mean Jeremy is this kind of look okay
with both of those things being orange
yeah it should be fine I mean I'll be
labeled I think I'll be okay okay all
right okay then we have a solution for
this did you have a chance to work on
those icons yet Jeremy I don't know if
I've been I don't think I have a
notebook from Tyler yet ought to do that
offline okay fine um
okay I think that's everything for
Jeremy so far as I know um cool okay
discuss yes we very very fast
so basically oh sorry I'm gonna leave
right yep okay one of our viewers is
asking about currying of net encoder
I don't you think that makes sense yeah
it is curried already it scurried
feeding in its data I don't think it
makes any sense to curry in its options
because I think that's since it
sometimes doesn't have options it's
better to have the the options in the
main sort of package um okay sorry what
what were you going to say
so yes the last design discussion we
wanted was you know discussion
previously about different position for
net rain
and we previously thought that for
target device we can have like v1
hundreds it was the V 100 GPU supports
very optimally like float16 training and
we've decided that we think working
precision with a string argument like
real 32 or real 16 is practing this oh
boy for what is this for this is for nap
train
when I train another viewer question
here what about the the the dashes for
the problem is that if the dashes are
all yeah I mean if you scale the dashes
it well the problem is is that if it
gets very jagged then the dashes in the
looking I know look look the dashes end
up not even you know arty it's like like
putting rulers on the edge of a
coastline or something you know but okay
let's go back to UM to the Internet
Train thing um so what is the issue the
issue is target device okay so the issue
is that we want to be able to control
what precision we do training at and it
can be very useful to do lower precision
training so so what I say so if I just
say working for such an hour or eight
you're not happy with that because we
only support certain discretes
types so it's not I mean if you think
about it the working precision you know
as an option which is documented on its
own page and what on earth are we going
to say on that page about this well if
it's a string that's called real 32 we
can put a little note like for next
train real 32 in real 16 try and sell it
to mark for working precision in general
it's not completely stupid for working
precision in general we could call it
training precision and have it be a
different symbol well is it in fact
working precision or is it training
precision I mean it's doing that sounds
like a different kind of thing
it is working precision because we can
also do a valuation at their precision
okay
well alright so listen listen to my mind
that working precision thing with a type
like that it's something that will be
relevant when the compiler exists anyway
that's true why don't you send out a
note to the numerix group and just say
you want to do this for this net train
thing maybe it's relevant for something
more general does anybody have a
fundamental objection to this new mix I
think it's an L - numerix okay um and
you may get back some some venomous
stuff I have no idea toxic pile
yeah um okay and I think else we need to
go over not for now great cool okay okay
all right
see y'all soon okay who sent me go that
was in the chat okay I need that font
okay no no that's what I got
okay